children mining the Democratic Republic
of Congo is rich in minerals but most
are poor here and the young are working
everywhere it's often the only way to
survive we're searching for two little
boys we last saw months ago
it takes us six hours retracing our
steps from the mining capital of Lu Baba
she mostly on unmade roads into the
heart of the former Katanga province
this is rough territory and we complete
the remaining three kilometers on foot
jumbled jumbled we're heading for a
remote nomadic mining community hidden
in the bush where we first spotted
Dawson and Richard then little Dawson
had just eight years old was struggling
in attrocious conditions to help with a
cobalt mining he and his friend Richard
standing next to him and just a few
years older worked all day for a
pittance often not enough for either of
them to buy food Dawson was the image of
misery both had little hope for the
future later on in the year
- guess I'm going on
[Applause]
[Applause]
when we finally reach their village it
doesn't take long to track down both
boys down for each other though summers
John Boresha
Dawson's father's been digging new
tunnels but he's found no cobalt for
days so the two haven't eaten in four
table she forgot to pack
kimitaka pata do you sponsor reason - no
Sessa hvala Fatah makuta Bow Valley Zoo
token danny kaye abotu toda funded
Giannini parce que le Makuta digital
apat i do ad to see field Dawson's
father ya cent and his partner have
already dug six meters into the ground
they have no protective equipment and
few tools just a couple of shovels and
they're doing this knowing their
previous three tunnels have collapsed
but hunger is a powerful motivator
Dawson's not allowed in the tunnel it's
too dangerous but he and Richard help
out on the surface emptying the bags of
soil almost as big as themselves so the
sacks can be filled again there's a
chance the boys can be educated John
Bosco and jean bosco is the key his
organization's offering to sponsor
Dawson and Richard at a boarding school
more than a hundred miles away in
lubumbashi but the boys fathers have to
agree their decisions are immediate they
want the boys to be given a chance its
Dawson's first trip outside his village
so his father gives him a wash with no
water source close by this is a very
rare experience
no sir I mean they were pursuing that
[Music]
banana
O'Bannon
so as I said I mean that wolf or I will
mean equal Dawson has never known
anything but working on the mines he's
never known halter to come out of attack
and never experienced electricity
whatever this has been his home since he
was one year old
[Music]
you know a Medusa British give me profit
again where he's saying goodbye to
everything and everyone he's ever known
the two boys now face a very different
future to those they leave behind and
they wave excitedly to their friends
they're accompanied by Richards father
who will check out the new school
Dawson's father has worked to do
tunneling by the time we reach
lubumbashi it's nighttime
it's an unrecognizable new world for the
boys with streets packed with traders
and buyers waiting to greet them at the
house where they'll stay for the next
few months are their fellow students a
mixture of orphans and street children
with no homes
the boys are shown round this is run by
the [ __ ] Valley Oh charity which means
Children's Sanctuary and Swahili there's
no electricity but there are bathrooms a
proper roof and for the first time the
boys will sleep on Chaucer's ash Debian
you can help you I feel happy to be here
what does it feel like being on on a
proper bed hashtag and Roberta mission
and occupy I feel very good because it
that's my home I never seek to live less
like this next morning the boys have had
a haircut and been given new clothes and
there's another first breakfast of
baguette aunty from now on they'll have
three meals a day then it's into a
classroom they're getting a crash course
in reading and writing with more
personal tutoring here before joining
the local school but for those more used
to manual work it takes a lot of
concentration the Camellia workers chat
to Dawson to learn about his daily life
on the cobalt mine comes our local
potato chosen water indicator
kinetochore my other pocket in Aakash
how about a kaput I could overcome
adversity Nisha could run along John
Jellicoe better for dipping my share the
two boys are given their school uniforms
they have a chance to turn their lives
around
Dawson has never even owned a pair of
shoes before the bags on their backs
will now be filled with schoolbooks
rather than soil or minerals but they
leave behind countless other children
still being exploited
Alex Crawford Sky News in the Democratic
Republic of Congo